[Musique]
mais gaël duval bonjour bonjour ont déjà
candidat à l'élection municipale à
saint-esprit il y a 6 ans vous aviez
recueilli 9 % des suffrages au premier
tour et vous aviez me semble-t-il
ensuite contribué en partie à la
victoire de fred michel tir haut au
second tour face au maire sortant
d'alors eric ayotte
du coup un miguel duval comme vous êtes
à nouveau candidat cette année
de ce point de vue comment analysez-vous
succinctement la mandature 2014-2020
celle qui s'achève là celle de monsieur
tyro alors bonsoir bonsoir ce quart où
j'étais bon soir au peuple si vite après
un budget moi vous dire monsieur k ruse
que je n'ai participé à aucun conflit
mais a pour maître monsieur triaud en
place il ya eu des candidats qui se sont
rassemblés bien avant l'échéance
officielle et je n'ai participé à aucune
réunion nouvelle mais nous nous en
tiendrons compte vous aviez appelé à
voter fred michel thiry entourons de la
souffrance de la population et de la
souffrance des employés municipaux
j'ai demandé à la population d'agir en
son âme et conscience et de de confirmer
la sanction donc pour un changement vous
avez vous voulez un changement est comme
ça écouter la population elle et je suis
à son écoute un donc coton du décès de
ces souffrances observé voilà que nous
avons agi mais je n'ai participé je
préfère le préciser non mais vous avez
raison c'est pourquoi je vous ai posé la
question je ne suis allé au micro de
personnes pour dire votez fois de michel
thibault très bien alors votre analyse
justement de cette mandature cette
première mandature de de fred michel
giraud et son équipe alors 2014 a
représenté pour le peuvent spiritains de
dire ou non à 27 ans d'une gestion qui a
vraiment mis le saint-esprit dans une
impasse et dans le même temps elle
disait oui elle disait oui à l'espoir et
à la corde et sa confiance mais vous
vous rendez compte que six ans seulement
six ans après mais cette population
s'est sentie envahi par la déception est
à considérer que sa confiance accordée a
été bafoué
sensible à leurs marques et répondre
justement à l'appel de beaucoup d'entre
eux
ben écoute et voilà je répondu à cet
appel je suis de nouveau candidat mais à
toute simplicité en toute humilité pour
proposer alors attendez vous avez vous
un soutien voire même une investiture
d'un parti ou d'un mouvement politique
poursuit russie
je suis investi comme en 2014 par le
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
je ne mets pas mon drapeau dans la
bouche quel est selon vous le premier
dossier urgent qu'il faudrait saisir si
vous étiez élu maire de saint-esprit
dans deux mois à peu près à leurs côtés
dans notre démarche est celle de mon
parti l'humain est au centre de nos
préoccupations
s'il y a des personnes à mettre en
sécurité là aujourd'hui ce sont les
auprès de la mairie
et je ne compte pas aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas fait valoir leur droit de
retrait de retrait parce qu'on va très
bien qu'il y à un bâtiment très affecté
celui là mais de saint-esprit
il ya des fissures intérieur même si
monsieur thibault a annoncé une promesse
de monsieur marc de 500000 euros pour
réparer je n'ai pas entendu long d'une
prévention quelconque pour les mettre en
sécurité
en attendant ces 5000 ces cinq cent
mille euros autre chose
toujours pressé dans l'humain je suis en
train de penser aux habitants de la cité
régal qui au moment où nous parlons là
après 30 ans n'ont pas obtenu leur titre
de propriété
c'est à dire que ces gens sont condamnés
à rester là alors qu'ils ont fini de
payer leur loyer
non j'ai pas compris et je ne comprends
toujours pas comment un maire sortant
qui a une formation juridique ne les a
pas accompagné sur ce plan là on
rappelle que fred michel terrot est
avocat de profession
plus globalement un miguel du valais
c'est la dernière question quel est
l'enjeu à vos yeux essentiel pour les
habitants spiritains et et leur ville là
avec à lot
c'est à ce prix comme les autres
communes n'est plus isolée
nos appartenant à une communauté
d'agglomération qu'on appelle l'espace
sud
le cetas put droite est et peut-être une
force de proposition nous avons la
chance de ne pas subir la pollution des
sargasses nous avons la chance de ne pas
subir la pollution des grandes voies
routières nous sommes à l'intérieur des
terres
nous sommes dotés de cinq sorties donc
cet environnement rural sever nous
devons la préserver et en faire un atout
les touristes aujourd'hui n'est pas
forcément besoin d'aller à la plage ils
ont besoin de consommer les fruits de
saison d'être à proximité des habitants
et nous devons faire de cet
environnement
un atout principal il ya d'autres bien
sûr on peut pas développer le pas tout
gagné je n'ai pas non plus proposée
présente mes projets aux idées mais
manifestement vous avez un intérêt pour
l'agritourisme développement de
l'agritourisme et à saint-aignan
absolument monsieur en cours en tenant
compte ils font tourner ou quoi merci
mais gaël duval d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans sa ou caddie spécial
municipal je vous en prie et merci à
vous